hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to cuphead now we've
made it quite a bit of progress so far
but things are getting harder and harder
every step of the way but that doesn't
mean that I'm gonna give up or take it
easy on myself I actually am good at
shmups which is something that people
don't tend to believe hey another crime
is that you buddy
Oh God you don't need to scream to me
like that
okay but what's good about this is
nothing because I don't want anything
from you even though I'll probably have
to buy it eventually precision is key I
mean that's pretty cool I like the
everyone knows everyone was on about the
lobber so I'll get that but that doesn't
promise that I'm gonna use it bye see
you buddy
so I just need to explore around find
another boss and get right into it
where are you using some crab ah good
another area fun fair fever okay that
sounds bad but I'll go for it I guess if
I actually remember how to play the game
which is probably not true doo doo doo
doo doo doo I'm on it all right I don't
like it already yeah no thank you I
don't trust that
oh well that's horrifying
oh no Perry I tried so hard no I can't
bury you oh man well that was a terrible
start to a terrible terrible terrible
run all right hang on yeah yeah whatever
go away bubbling huh blowing husky
monkey that's a Perry
Wow did that work at all I have no idea
the bean chase I tried to parry
I tried maybe I shouldn't actually try
to parry that's probably where I'm
making my first mistake there we go
you got this one hey you slap slap oh
come on if I don't if I see if I don't
slap with them do they still good oh god
I'm not oh you know what ah the beam its
the beam all right fine I'm gonna stop
digging around here I'm just trying to
be fancier than I really am which is
always my first mistake
Oh y-you cornered me
you sack of [ __ ] oh well tits too you
slap a doctor damn it
slap and don't work on you Wow doesn't
work if I display my stupid head in your
ass which is usually my go-to strategy
for any time I'm feeling nervous good no
okay slapping slapping doesn't work
gonna slap a [ __ ] is that all right
fine I don't need you anymore no what if
I get the ball the ball would have
bounced on it or something all right
whatever okay there we go
whoa nope going away running away
run anyway slappa but I'm running I slap
it and then I run up oh geez you sack of
[ __ ] oh god damn it god I don't know
what these balloons are getting me I
killed all the bosses like in no time at
all and these [ __ ] balloons nope
didn't I go over the stupid thing I
don't want to slap you it's a little too
early to get angry this is the first
video I'm recording today and I really
don't want to get grumpy about it I'm
really done that's the last thing that I
want to do right now oh no no no okay
Sally slapping needs to God you sack of
[ __ ] I hate you so much
you stupid I'm a slap of the [ __ ] out of
you okay we're Han
Oh get that combo oh hell yeah whoops
all right all right
slapping this boot I was just goofing it
I stupid piece of poop maybe if I don't
shoot the balloons they won't pop up oh
it's me shooting them that makes him pop
up I'm a stupid it was all my fault
Oh slappa yeah I mean slapping you that
hard all right no okay oh my god that
was so close okay firing is now back on
game on
oh you can't die that's why you'd be so
douche ah is this whole place is better
if I don't shoot anybody maybe that's
like the thing I don't know what these
are all about and I don't like it oh no
oh no no no no no yeah okay all right
this seems horrible why is this even a
thing please barely slapping alive no I
was slapping I was slapping oh god I
don't know okay so just don't shoot I
see the problem my problem was I was
killing everybody in this lovely circus
when in reality I was the evil one he's
just trying to catch my fall helping me
along everything's fine this guy's just
trying to show me some magic I'm just
killing everybody indiscriminately which
is awfully a horrible thing to do this
is just a fun dunk tank and yet here I
am murder
dad-dad excellent that's what I wanted
sure wish I had my spread shot that
would be perfectly is boyar very
incredibly useful God that spread shot
is incredibly whoa hey you son to tits
good stop it not only is Cuddyer all
right there we go okay we're making it
we're doing it oh yeah [ __ ] I just made
it hard for myself no I was fine and
then I goofed it I'm such a tit sprinkle
oh I don't know what you are but you're
gonna get shot from ah why that seems
hardly fair no no no no why are you sure
we're good poor flock of ducks just
going by okay you're the murderer here
That's not me oh that seems up here okay
all right no snap snap snap
cool snowy that's gross
not today not today not today not today
not today I'm I'm watching you I'm
watching you baby stop now who's doing
it snack snack free its new creations
snicker eats snatch treat I don't
remember what it was same good God just
stop there we go okay there we go oh
yeah that took way more effort than it
ever should have I'm very sorry
everybody that that should have gone
much more smoothly than that but it did
not oh wait I get ya terrible all right
bad oh yeah mmm
yeah probably gonna get a C+ I'll take
it okay whatever
hello you can't catch me unless you take
a shortcut that's what some punk kids
did last week it's only the only way
that could have beaten me to the rides
so maybe you could show me where the
shortcut is you're around here Oh No
maybe whoo what is this what are you a
VI reaction okay sure whatever sure yeah
it's gonna go well for me oh boy I'm up
you want bombs you want bombs oh yeah
Bravo oh you got a pride okay you got a
problem and I don't have the solution
cuz my solution core welp oh boy oh boy
okay hang on all right everybody hold on
to your hats oh that was very close
slapper well
dangerous huh got right off frickin puke
egg right in the face all right we got
this okay so far so good with the
machine gun seems to be the better
strategy for this this poor part is
heard this bird you heard damn it I
didn't mean to kill the slap a bird huh
slap no no easy easy easy easiest thing
in the world
yeah why did I go into that why is
slapping you sack of [ __ ] here I come
you
[Music]
yeah you better be toasty oh well if I
kill myself on the slap up in you ain't
gonna even need to worry about me
because I'm incredibly stupid my
stupidity knows no limits to be
perfectly honest oh god I was not paying
it to slap by going from the flying
mechanics to the - ah God why did I
meant to boom apparently oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy I'm gonna get that slapper
okay oh Jesus star to see ya you better
you better be tired no no no no no come
on now what are you doing whoa hard to
see hard to see hard to see hard to see
hard to see
alright hard to see sassy so man is poor
mothers sacrificing all of its children
to try to be me BAM
whoa I walked right into that one that
was entirely my fault I mean obviously
everything I'm doing is my fault
yeah you better get mad what are you
gonna do get more mad how you stupid a
leg that's good doing it good for you
slap got the slap slap your baby oh no
it's just whoo hey no need for that Wow
oh hi baby I thought I'd kill her your
baby but apparently not huh boom there
you go Hey wow this seems hazardous Hey
whoa I could have slapped with that but
I just I let you go I went easy on you
yeah
god dammit I'm not paying attention for
the slapper this is stupid babies is
distracting me ah stop you freakin
mastermind douche it's our dad no I was
always looking right at it oh damn it
okay my dad to the Brawn and I'm all
brains together we bring the pain except
your dad now sorry
and I got this easy-peasy yeah yeah yeah
you're stupid Tantra [ __ ]
see this is the sort of stuff that I can
deal with I can deal with I can deal
with like bullet-hell dodges like this
is this totally fine for me well I mean
I say that and watch I'm about to be hit
because I'm gonna try to go for the slap
book and I did it my schumak shimmy good
slappa thank you for the the power I
went the wrong way
ah no I got it got too close for the
yeah for the shootie oh boy oh god damn
it Wow
for some reason I just am not paying
attention to that when I should yeah
doing good though doing good though
doing good though making progress
come on come on come on you big bird
bastard just give my Bob Drive I can't
mi sorry that was a disappointing thing
I'm just as disappointed as you guys are
all right come on you big bird bastard
just eat my bombs you bird bastard you
banana bulging beep I said a censor
because it was sawed ace is what I said
it slap slap how do you feel about this
[ __ ] bomb
oh god I've ran right into it didn't
even think about my Dodge wow I am an
idiot oh man idiotic Pichardo boink
getting fancy getting fancy fancy feet
oh ha ha
that's what I pay for my fancy feet here
we go boink and slapper hodo all right
you you brain you pinky and the brain
wannabe you brain pinky Pat doodle doo
slapping me slap oh very good
whoa okay Emma give me another give me a
slap okay well you are about to feel the
wrath of the bomb
oh yeah oh no what's gonna do now you're
gonna call on Papa oh [ __ ] he called on
Papa hey hey hey oh you didn't I didn't
know you're gonna split up there
ah [ __ ] god damn it every time I go see
a new area every time ah come on nut
slap damn you made me miss the slapper
you make me not kill one of your
children how could [ __ ] you got me there
that was that was a good one you
definitely got me there
boink that needle alright you're gonna
get it slap slap bomb bomb bomb in your
we go here come the bombs Bam Bam Bam
Bam Bam Bam
but that's all why do you ever why do
you what is your heart ah I didn't know
it'd go diagonal either oh you stupid
piece of [ __ ] oh you piece of [ __ ] oh
you're just escaping death now oh you're
just prolonging the inevitable you bird
piece of poop oh what's that
Oh super super in your face I'm sorry
was that not supposed to happen
cut it up seemed like pre appropriate to
me I almost got fancy I almost got fancy
no way no way I did not get hit by that
that is [ __ ] my controllers broken
my dad works at Nintendo oh no what's
this immediate abou Mitch that sucks so
bad for you oh well you got what are you
up we go ah no oh no oh no there's bad
place to be in and predicted object
permanence is my strong suit poink oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah oh good did you see how I
dodged that bad boy did you see how I
dodged that bad boy oh you saw how I
dodged that bad boy did you not all
right come on whoa why Oh slap it no
miss me
zapper okay you know what I'm a I don't
think I'm gonna getting up what is that
I don't know what that is but I like it
you [ __ ] oh yeah puts salt that's
horrifying they're putting salt on him
that's no good that's that's actually
terrible that's that's horrifying
Oh God why would they doing that why
would they do that that sounds that's
just awful oh my god
see pretty good pretty good pretty good
okay let's carry on a little bit you
want more out of this what a rush
what a rush to be amazing oh is that the
other mausoleum wall-e warbles and son
don't forget about son he's in there to
death it is well Oh what are you doing
who are you Doug do so have you spoken
with quadratus the watery being across
the aisle that is something few others
can claim all right well okay all right
mausoleum - oh do I get to slap her okay
all right
nope slapper or you want the slapper oh
you're gonna get the slapper oh come on
give me a combo here give me something
to actually give me a challenge up
slappa slappa slappa slappa slappa what
was that I saw that miss yeah okay
you can't escape from the slap-a- that's
another thing that I'm good at not that
I'm bragging but if something goes off
off screen I usually can keep track of
it like that's what I mean by object
permanence I saw that Oh two of them eh
oh I thought I was gonna get both at
once no this is bad I was pressing I was
pressing my markiplier get with it be
gooder I got this right there got ya
okay give me a my double I know you got
the double oh oh come on no come on I
was focused on the ah ha I was focused
on the other side I was trying to be
fancy again I can't be fancy in this
game god I can't be fancy
I'm just so stupid god I wish I wasn't
dumb you guys know how dumb I am
yeah I wish I was not that not today I
don't know I think just touch this urn
oh [ __ ] uh fancy fancy feet I don't know
why if they just touch this urn it's
like the end of it this poor person got
trapped in this urn and just like that's
it we rubbed out of existence dan uh got
two for all going keys
oh I was so close everytime slappa
slappa
oh no slapper okay alright hey zoom if I
knew I rooted around here I could find
something special for you but I didn't
know I'd get trapped again thanks for
saving me a second time
take this magical super art and saw see
if I can find in another thank you I
don't know why you're doing this for me
are you like my grandma or something you
grandma cup you Cup grandma you gram Cup
ma oh I got another super let's see what
no let's see what this one is
invincibility cross the astral plane and
become invulnerable for a short time
well that does seem useful that does
seem useful but it's also a crutch so I
ain't gonna do that ain't gonna do that
think I'm fine yeah I'm fine I'm fine
without it
okay so anyway that's all the time I got
for cuphead in this episode thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you thought down the comments
below I'm gonna carry on with this very
soon so thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]